ADDING TO THE UNPRECEDENTED
PROBLEM THE ADMINISTRATION IS
FACING.
BRIAN: MORE THAN ANY TIME IN OUR
LIFETIME.
LET’S BRING IN CHAD WOLF, FORMER
ACTING DHS SECRETARY.
YOU HAVE SEEN THIS BEFORE BUT
NOT THIS NUMBER.
WHAT CHANGED?
>> WHAT I CAN TELL YOU IS A
FULL-BLOWN CRISIS ON THE BORDER
AT THE MOMENT.
WHAT HAS CHANGED IS THE
MESSAGING OUT OF THE
ADMINISTRATION.
IN 2019 UNDER DONALD TRUMP WE
HAD MESSAGING OF DON’T COME
BECAUSE YOU WILL NOT BE LET INTO
THE COUNTRY.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF THESE FOLKS
DON’T QUALIFY FOR ASYLUM BUT
UNFORTUNATELY TODAY WE HAVE A
DIFFERENT SET OF MESSAGING AND A
DIFFERENT SET OF POLICIES IN
PLACE WHICH ARE ENCOURAGING, THE
FACTORS WE SEE TODAY ENCOURAGING
THIS CRISIS.
AINSLEY: LET’S LISTEN TO
PRESIDENT BIDEN AND GET YOUR
REACTION.
>> THE IDEA THAT JOE BIDEN SAID
COME, I HEARD THE OTHER DAY THEY
ARE COMING BECAUSE THEY KNOW I
AM A NICE GUY.
HERE IS THE DEAL.
THEY ARE NOT.
>> YOU SAY CLEARLY DON’T COME?
>> YES.
WHAT WE’RE IN THE PROCESS OF
GETTING SET UP, DON’T LEAVE YOUR
TOWN OR CITY OR COMMUNITY.
JILLIAN: YOU HEARD JEFF SAY HE
INTERVIEWED THAT MIGRANT AND THE
MAN SAID THAT IS NOT THE MESSAGE
BEING SPREAD DOWN HERE.
IT IS BEING SPREAD TO COME.
>> DHS OFFICIAL SECRETARY TALKS
FROM THE WHITE HOUSE PODIUM
SAYING YOU CAN COME BUT DON’T
COME NOW.
THE MESSAGING IS NOT CONSISTENT
BUT AT THE END OF THE DAY THESE
ILLEGAL MIGRANTS DON’T LISTEN TO
GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS.
THEY LISTEN TO OTHER ILLEGALS
WHO HAVE GOTTEN INTO THE US,
CALL THEM AND TELL THEM THEY ARE
HERE, STAYING IN THE US, NOT
BEING DEPORTED OR REMOVED.
THAT IS HOW -- WHAT THEY ARE
LISTENING TO.
AS LONG AS THEY SEE OTHER
INDIVIDUALS COMING INTO THE US,
BEING CATCH AND RELEASED INTO
THE US AND STAYING HERE YOU WILL
CONTINUE TO SEE THIS SURGE.
LAWRENCE: WASN’T AS PART OF THE
PLAN ALL ALONG?
HERE’S JOE BIDEN TALKING ABOUT
IN 2019, WE NEED MORE IMMIGRANTS
HERE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WE COULD AFFORD TO TAKE IN A
HEARTBEAT 2 MILLION PEOPLE.
THE IDEA THE COUNTRY OF 330
MILLION PEOPLE CANNOT ABSORB
PEOPLE WHO ARE IN DESPERATE NEED
AND ARE JUSTIFIABLY FEEL BEING
-- FLEEING PRESSURE IS
ABSOLUTELY BIZARRE.
I WOULD MOVE TO INCREASE THE
TOTAL NUMBER OF IMMIGRANTS ABLE
TO COME TO THE UNITED STATES.
LAWRENCE: WHAT IS YOUR REACTION?
>> Reporter: WHAT I WOULD SAY
THE US IS THE MOST WELCOMING
COUNTRY IN THE WORLD WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT REFUGEES BUT THE
FACTS ALSO DISPUTE A LOT OF WHAT
WAS SAID.
90% OF THESE INDIVIDUALS DON’T
QUALIFY FOR ASYLUM, ARE NOT
BEING PERSECUTED UNDER THE
ASYLUM LAWS WE HAVE TODAY.
WE HAVE TO REMOVE THEM.
IF THEY COME TO THE US, WE DO
CATCH AND RELEASE, WE HAVE TO GO
OUT AND FIND THEM AND REMOVE
THEM AND THAT IS AN INHUMANE
POLICY AND INHUMANE MESSAGE WE
WANT TO SEND TO FOLKS, TRY TO
GET INTO THE US, STAY HERE FOR A
YEAR AND BE REMOVED TO YOUR HOME
COUNTRY.
NOT THE RIGHT MESSAGE AND
FEELING THIS CRISIS.
BRIAN: IT IS RIGHT TO JUMP THE
LINE, FILLING OUT THE FORMS,
GOING BY OUR LAWS, MEANWHILE
GUESS WHAT, IT IS YOUR FAULT
ACCORDING TO THE NEW DHS
SECRETARY WHO BLAMES THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION, QUOTE, THE PRIOR
ADMINISTRATION DISMANTLED THE
ASYLUM SYSTEM.
WE HAVE TO REBUILD THE ENTIRE
SYSTEM INCLUDING THE POLICIES,
PROCEDURES REQUIRED TO
ADMINISTER ASYLUM LAWS CONGRESS
PASSED LONG AGO.
THE PRIOR ADMINISTRATION TORE
DOWN THE LAWFUL PATHWAYS THAT
HAVE BEEN DEVELOPED FOR CHILDREN
TO COME TO THE UNITED STATES IN
A SAFE EFFICIENT ORDERLY WAY.
THE PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATIVE CUT
FOREIGN AID TO THE NORTHERN
TRIANGLE.
DO YOU WANT TO DEAL WITH THOSE
FACTS AS THEY SEE THEM?
>> ABSOLUTELY A COUPLE POINTS
ARE MADE.
WE WANT TO GIVE ONE OF THE MOST
SECURE BORDERS WE HAVE EVER HAD.
WE GAVE THEM A NETWORK OF
POLICIES THAT ALLOW THEM TO
QUICKLY REMOVE INDIVIDUALS, TO
SEEK PROTECTION CLOSER TO THEIR
HOME COUNTRIES IN THE NORTHERN
TRIANGLE AND PROVIDE THE ASYLUM
SYSTEM.
ALL OF IT WAS WORKING.
WE BRIEFED THE TRANSITION TEAM,
GAVE THE RESULTS, THEY DECIDED
TO REMOVE THESE POLICIES, WHAT
WOULD HAPPEN, THE FACT THAT THEY
ARE
ARE NOT PREPARED TODAY’S QUITE
UNCONSCIONABLE.
WE TALK ABOUT ASYLUM SYSTEM
SAYING THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
TORE THAT DOWN, NOTHING COULD BE
FURTHER FROM THE TRUTH.
HE HIRED 500 ASYLUM OFFICERS,
ADDRESSED THE ASYLUM BACKLOG IN
FOUR YEARS OF THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION, DHS AND DOJ GAVE
MORE PEOPLE ASYLUM IN THE LAST
FOUR YEARS OF THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION SO THE CLAIM THAT
WE TORE DOWN THE SYSTEM IS
SIMPLY NOT BACKED UP BY THE
FACTS.
BRIAN: YOU RESTORED THE AID WHEN
THEY WERE RESPONSIVE TO REQUESTS
TO REIN IN THEIR POPULATION.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
WE HOLD THEM ACCOUNTABLE.
WANTED TO SEE RESULTS BEFORE WE
PROVIDED THE MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
IN FOREIGN AID AND THAT IS HOW
IT SHOULD BE.
WE SIGN OVER A DOZEN DIFFERENT
AGREEMENTS WITH THE NORTHERN
TRIANGLE AND HAD THE BEST
COOPERATION AND RESTORED THE
FOREIGN ASSISTANCE WHEN WE SAW
THOSE RESULTS.
AINSLEY: IS THAT MONEY GOING TO
THESE TRIABLE COUNTRIES SO THEY
CAN FIX THE PROBLEM WHERE THEY
HAVE OPPRESSION, PERSECUTION OR
THEY DO HAVE FOLKS WHO WANT TO
COME OVER HERE AND CLAIM ASYLUM
BECAUSE THEY ARE DANGEROUS AREAS
WHERE THEY LIVE.
ARE USING THAT MONEY TO FIX THAT
PROBLEM?
>> USING FOREIGN ASSISTANCE
FUNDING FOR CORRUPTION ISSUES IN
THE NORTHERN TRIANGLE AND BORDER
SECURITY.
THE ROOT CAUSES OF THAT, AND IN
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION, REALLY
GREAT RESULTS, DID NOT HAVE ANY
MIGRANT CARAVANS IN 2020 UNDER
THESE AGREEMENTS AND WE DID NOT